hallo liebe zuschauer in den vergangenen
monaten hatten wir ein thema was immer
wieder viel diskutiert wurde in unseren
kommentaren und dass das thema migration
und flucht und wir haben uns überlegt
dass wir heute das thema noch mal aus
einer anderen perspektive beleuchten
wollen deswegen sind nach osnabrück
gereist und besuchen hier hernold man
sie sind hier studiendekan am institut
für internationale migration und
interkulturelle studien
wir werden jetzt mal ein gespräch mit
ihnen führen dankeschön dass sich zeit
genommen haben danke schön und wir haben
uns überlegt wir bringen auch eure
kommentare mit ryan deshalb haben wir
jetzt mal einige kommentare vor allem
auch kritische kommentare gegen ja zum
thema migration die wir heute mal
beleuchten möchten aus der perspektive
verschiedener perspektive aber auch mit
antworten von einem experten und
johannes spielt jetzt diese fragen
stellen
also wir haben fünf fragen fünf dessen
thesen mit gebracht das sind themen die
unter uns in filmen in den kommentaren
angefragt werden und die erste frage ist
steigt in deutschland die kriminalität
bedingt durch die flüchtlinge
nein so pauschal kann man das nicht
sagen
wir haben relativ wenig informationen
darüber
die informationen die in diesem kontext
entwickelt werden kommen aus der
polizeilichen kriminalstatistik das
heißt alles das was bei der polizei
angezeigt wird wird in diesem
zusammenhang registriert hier ist
tatsächlich die der anteil von
asylsuchenden überproportional hoch
allerdings hat das auch damit zu tun
dass zum einen wesentlich stärker
gegenüber menschen die aus anderen
ländern kommen
angezeigt wird häufiger angezeigt wird
als bei menschen die in der
bundesrepublik
und zweitens sehen wir dass unter den
asylsuchenden besonders viele junge
männer sind und junge männer sind
diejenigen die ohnehin egal woher sie
kommen ob sie seit ewigkeiten in der
bundesrepublik leben oder nicht ganz
konkret eben höhere anzahl von
straftaten oder kriminellen vergehen
begehen
das heißt also wenn man ihn jetzt diese
faktoren herausrechnet
nämlich dass das anzeigeverhalten ein
sehr spezifisches bei menschen die aus
dem ausland kommen zweitens dass es eben
um junge männer geht sehen wir insgesamt
gesehen ist die kriminalitätsrate bei
denen die zugewandert sind niedriger als
bei der einheimischen bevölkerung also
das nächste thema ist viele menschen
behaupten dass das großteil von den
flüchtlingen gar keine politischen
flüchtlinge sind sondern
wirtschaftsflüchtlinge sind menschen die
gehört haben in deutschland lebt ist
sich sehr bequem und ich muss nur mich
so ein bisschen da
da stellen als ein politischer
flüchtling und und schon kann ich mir
mein leben hier organisieren
natürlich gibt es menschen die in die
unsere kommen asylstatus haben möchten
aber letztlich einen solchen ausschuss
nicht bekommen dafür gibt es ja die
entsprechenden verfahren es ist ein es
gibt seit langem einen großen apparat
der sich um asyl anzeige kümmert das
bundesamt für migration und flüchtlinge
ist dafür zuständig dass heißt es geht
ja nicht darum dass allen menschen die
kommen und tatsächlich ein solcher
asylstatus ein solcher schutzstatus
zugebilligt wird es gibt die
entsprechende überprüfung und werden wir
uns ganz konkrete fälle anschauen sehen
wir dass seit beginn des bürgerkriegs in
syrien 2011 die zahl der schüler die in
die bundesrepublik gekommen sind stark
angestiegen ist vor allen dingen
2014/2015 aber wir sehen auch dass eben
mit der verschärfung des konflikts mit
dem übergang von einem bürgerkrieg in
einen internationalen krieg in syrien
die zahl angestiegen ist wir können also
ganz explizit sehen hier unmittelbar
sehen was der hintergrund für diese
bewegung ist und wir wissen gleichzeitig
auch der allergrößte teil der menschen
die international als flüchtlinge gelten
kommen nicht nach europa können auch gar
nicht nach europa kommen weil die
möglichkeiten grenzen zu überschreiten
vor allen dingen auch kontinent ganzen
zu überschreiten ausgesprochen gering
sind
das nächste thema ist die mögliche
islamisierungs europa viele menschen
haben angst dass die menschen die die
flüchtlinge die nach deutschland kommen
sehr religiöse menschen sind und auch
den hund haben zu mischen sie denn den
wunsch haben in der religion zu
verbreiten und viele menschen haben
angst dass in absehbarer zeit in 20 30
jahren dank der höheren geburtenrate sie
nicht mehr in ihre eigene heimat
heimisch sind sondern in eine sich
flüssig in einer völlig anderen kultur
also zunächst aber muss man festhalten
dass die geburtenrate derjenigen die in
der bundesrepublik leben und zugewandert
sind nicht höher ist erstaunlicherweise
passen sich die geburtenraten sofort an
schon in der ersten generation und
zweitens also das was wir sehen ist dass
menschen die zugewandert sind
tatsächlich ein höheres ausmaß an
religiosität haben aber dieses ausmaß
nicht so hoch ist dass wir davon
ausgehen müssen religion sei das
zentrale element von alltag von
beispielsweise menschen die in den
vergangenen jahren gekommen sind
wir sehen dass religiosität in den
vergangenen jahrzehnten enorm an
bedeutung verloren hat auch in den
herkunftsstaaten enormen bedeutung an
bedeutung von 100 sowie in europa auch
wir sehen das aber im kontext von
migration religion der abfall ressource
darstellt warum menschen die
beispielsweise in die bonus zu bekommen
haben durchaus die neigung
beispielsweise moscheegemeinden
aufzusuchen weil sie hier auf menschen
treffen deren sprache sie sprechen mit
denen sich verständigen können die eben
auch hilfe leisten wenn es darum geht an
wohnungen heranzukommen im kontakt mit
behörden oder an arbeitsmöglichkeiten
heranzukommen das heißt also religiöse
gemeinden sind wenn man so will auch
helfer auf dem weg zur integration man
könnte sie als integrations agenturen
auch bezeichnen
das ist ein aspekt der
erstaunlicherweise eine diskussion so
gut wie überhaupt keine rolle spielt
meistens wird das element der gefahr
betont ohne ganz konkret sagen zu
können wohin diese gefahr besteht denn
wir wissen extreme politische
vorstellung also das was wir als
islamismus bezeichnet ist ja eine
politische vorstellung sind bei den
allerwenigsten menschen die eine
religiöse orientierung haben verbreitet
und von daher sehen wir zwar eine
gewisse bedeutung von religion aber wir
müssen diese bedeutung von religion
nicht ganz konkret verstehen als ein
anstieg von bedrohung von gefahren die
etwa in richtung auf terrorismus gehen
jetzt zum abschluss können wir noch ein
bisschen ein offenes gespräch führen
ich habe auch noch eine frage was nicht
so interessiert ist wieso wird dieses
thema migration so emotional behandelt
ja eine sehr schwierige frage weil wir
schon lange über diesen kontext debatten
führen aber nicht zu ergebnissen
gekommen sind würde ich es als eine sehr
schwierige frage verstehen
ich glaube es geht letztlich in diesen
diskussionen nicht um migration
es geht um andere dinge das heißt also
im kontext des redens von migration wenn
immer wieder ganz grundsätzliche fragen
aufgeworfen die gesellschaften
interessieren beziehungsweise die für
gesellschaften belang vor sind das heißt
also immer wenn es um das thema
migration geht geht es um die frage wer
ist wir
das heißt was hält gesellschaft zusammen
was trägt dazu bei dass wir uns
tatsächlich als etwas verstehen was eine
art von von kollektiv bildet das
zusammengehört wenn solche fragen nach
dem wir aufkommen stieg immer auch die
frage an wer gehört nicht dazu
also wenn wir uns mit der frage
beschäftigen was hält uns zusammen und
uns meine diesem zusammenhang deutsche
dann werden wir zu sehr
unterschiedlichen antworten kommen und
zwar zu sehr unterschieden antworten in
unterschiedlichen konstellationen je
nachdem wer wo auch fragt und wir werden
große mühe haben am ende deutlich machen
dem gegenüber was aus unserer sicht
jeweils als zentrale stichworte genannt
werden muss um ganz konkret am ende
sagen zu können ja das ist deutsch und
das
in deutscher oder das ist das was am
ende unsere gesellschaft auszeichnet
manche haben noch keine freie ich habe
ja auch sie sind ja historiker ich habe
auch geschichte studiert und ich würde
gerne wissen verliehen wenn sie jetzt
die möglichkeit hätten in die zukunft zu
weisen so 300 jahre von jetzt an den
sensoren bibliothek wie her und lesen
ein geschichtsbuch über die jetzige zeit
was würden wir da lesen was würden was
werden die leute rückblickend sagen auf
diese zeit also ich vermute dass wie
auch in den publikationen über die
vergangenheit die wir heute lesen
wahrscheinlich sehr stark über
politische zusammenhänge diskutiert
werden wird das heißt also vieles das
was wir heute im alltag diskutieren wird
in diesen publikationen er keinen platz
finden sondern wir werden reden über
große weltpolitische
auseinandersetzungen wir werden reden
über innenpolitische konflikte wie in
diesem kontext wird sicherlich da habe
ich mir sehr sicher dieses stichwort
flüchtlingskrise noch mal auftauchen mit
unterschieden konnten konnotationen den
blick auf die frage werden hier
eigentlich eine krise hat aber ich
glaube nicht dass in diesem zusammenhang
wirklich intensiv die fragen über die
wir in den vergangenen monaten
gesprochen haben empfahl dass diese
fragen über die wir in den vergangenen
monaten gesprochen haben im vordergrund
stehen werden schauen sie sich bitte die
darstellung an die wir heute lesen über
vergangenheit im 19 jahrhundert haben 55
bis 60 millionen europäerinnen europäer
den kontinent verlassen sind auf andere
kontinente gegangen
europa ist im 19 frühen zwanzigsten
jahrhundert komplett
durcheinandergewirbelt worden
eben vor dem hintergrund auch von
riesigen migration
schauen sie sich schul geschichtsbücher
anschauen sie sich geschichtsbücher an
die sich mit dem 19 jahrhundert
auseinander setzen diese themen kommen
nicht vor
das was im vordergrund steht ist krieg
ist frieden sind bestimmte große
politische debatten aber kaum etwas von
dem was tatsächlich migrationsgeschichte
angeht das scheint etwas zu sein was
gesellschaften offensichtlich relativ
schnell schlichtweg vergessen
danke schön dass sie sich diese zeit
genommen haben unser interview
sie haben wahrscheinlich schon häufiger
interviews gemacht in den letzten jahren
ja also bei dem thema bleibt das nicht
aus es sind x100 in den vergangenen
monaten gewesen weil einfach schlichtweg
und das scheint ja auch wichtig zu sein
das dürften ist danach erklärungen zu
bekommen sehr sehr stark war
ich denke das ist ein wichtiger aspekt
auch wissenschaftler ihnen diese nicht
entziehen wissenschaftlich eine
gesellschaftliche veranstaltungen wir
müssen also ganz explizit auch immer
wieder versuchen unsere perspektiven in
diese diskussion mit einzubringen
danke schon mal dafür wir hoffen dass es
euch gefallen hat dass ihr auch einige
vielleicht neue ideen bekommen habt und
ein paar neue dinge gehört habe schreibt
uns auf jeden fall eure kommentare eure
fragen dazu wir freuen uns darüber
und wenn ihr lust habt auch noch
vokabeln zu bekommen mit den themen zu
dem heutigen zu der heutigen diskussion
dann könnt ihr auch noch mal bei katrin
reingucken da bekommt ihr noch vokabeln
und grammatik übungen danke fürs
zuschauen und bis zum nächsten mal